no offense to the C but seriously this
image is getting darn near cliche a fish
is a ride on a shark Oh whale yeah yeah
we've got it
the fish is called a Remora but it's no
cliche it's actually far more
fascinating than it lets on if you
guessed that the Remora attaches to
other creatures with suction you'd be
right
what you might not know is that the fish
isn't suctioning with its mouth the
Remora suction cup is on the top of its
noggin check it out
nice hat brah that hat is it's highly
modified dorsal fin the same thing you'd
see a shark sticking out of the water
when the Remora is born the fin is on
its back where it's supposed to be but
migrates forward as the fish develops as
an adult by attaching to larger fish and
even marine mammals like dugongs the
Remora not only gets a free ride to save
energy but also a free meal if it's
stuck to a carnivore like a shark after
an attack
it'll gobble up the cloud to flesh with
its less aggro hosts it probably
intercepts parasites that fall off their
skin things like tiny crustaceans called
copepods the thing is model show remoras
can slow down their hosts significantly
that and they can end up rubbing their
hosts raw so a fish and rays don't seem
to mind the remoras these suckers might
in fact be parasitic like come on guys
ever heard of a personal bubble